et oui il suffit de bien se couvrir et
on peut parler de golf en toute saison
plein mois de janvier il fait froid mais
tant pis nous affrontons des frimas pour
ce nouveau numéro 2 par 78
[Musique]
au sommaire de ce numéro l'invité bill
owens loeb qui fait vivre le golf dans
les cités son interview et son swing
analysés par sébastien russier reportage
quand l'open de france en une nouvelle
dimension
découverte exclusive golfe de beibu
matériel pourquoi ne pas acheter des
clopes d'occasions pour déstockage et
enfin comme chaque numéro
le conseil des champions
[Musique]
l'invité de ce nouveau numéro 2 par
soixante dix huit c'est un homme assez
extraordinaire c'est un anglais il a
fait beaucoup de choses dans sa ville
était prof de golf il était pro cup il
s'occupe surtout des enfants des cités
et des banlieues grâce avec le golfe
il s'appelle bill owens ni lohan second
jour tellement je suis ravi de vous
rencontrer
bon on vous surnomme souvent le golfeur
cité on va savoir pourquoi parce que
vous avez créé une association qui
s'appelle golf éducatif avec les jeunes
de banlieue et des cités qui vous
apprenez du golfe et vous voyez aussi ce
que le golf peut leur apporter avoir
paré mais je vais quand même d'abord
parler un peu de vous alors dis souvent
le gallois bill owens gallois faisait
quand même né à liverpool
né à liverpool mais paralysante
déménageurs pega quand j'avais 7 ans à
temps vous êtes devenu propriété en auto
professionnel de foot professionnel
win-win apparemment le foot mais parce
que mon père a voulu surtout que son
fils devient folle avec le maillot rouge
mais en fait quand on déménage on peut
galles le sport fatidique à l'école
c'est le rugby
mais quand on est anglais et en arrivant
régal on est ainsi privé les autres
toutes les monstres city possible dans
le cadre de quoi casser trois fois vous
attend sur d'autres landais si
privilégié pour les gallois et un jour
ma mère m'emmenait dans une petite
brocante y aurait un petit sac avec
quatre clubs du gard se racheter sa
pauvre livre à l'époque c'était cher ma
miss ado mais m'a vraiment d'hier va et
c'est ça j'avais 16 ans et un an et demi
plus tard est devenu professeur il ya un
an et demi plus tard et a beau jour vous
arrivez en france je crois que c'est à
nous gens de retrouvent parlait pas un
mot de français qui cherchent un profond
si manger avec anthony hollandais tel
gouffre en france qui m'ont proposé un
boulot pour six mois pour initier des
les ondées qui venaient en stage pour
une semaine sur le cas du perche
on a joué aussi à belem alors comment il
est arrivé le golf éducatif dans votre
vie en grande bretagne le golfe allaient
beaucoup plus il peut plaire populaire
il ya quasiment dans toutes les grandes
villes anglaises mini sky ce monde où
les gens ils ont accès assez facile donc
quand on arrive en france on voit très
bien que le vaste majorité des parcours
sont en dehors des villes des gens n'ont
pas accès facile donc c'est devenu un
jour de chalon jude et bien comment je
parle de l'hygiène dans le golfe s'est
donc vous construisez souvent des
parcours va d'été d'hérault la boue des
pratiques sous des débits jackpot
tout va bien tout au début les des
pratiques presque c'est vrai que à
l'époque j'avais pas notre fameuse balle
légère
alors j'ai dit là justement c'était
andré roques il à 93 ans dont andrey et
c'est lui qui a trouvé cette balle et ça
nous a permis justement démange les
dégâts il faut dire que c'est une balle
qui est plus légère oui elles vont à peu
près un tiers de nos trajectoires ce qui
fait que sur eux sur une distance qui
n'est pas très long on peut jouer tous
les clubs
on peut jouer comme aujourd'hui toutes
les golf éducatif que nous on imagine
sont justement un tiers la distance
d'une vraie gaza donc de passage par la
suite pour les jeunes qui développe la
retirer à l'activité
ils passent très facilement par la suite
sur un wagon en multipliant tout
simplement l'existence par trois alors
vous avez aujourd'hui créer combien de
lieux comme ça je crois qu'il ya 17 3 me
qui existent un peu partout en france
alors quel est le rapport ces jeunes au
golf qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'ils y trouvent
et qu'est ce que ça leur apporte tout
tous les valeurs de galles c'est tout ce
qu'on a besoin de lever des valeurs ils
avaient longuement design vis-à-vis de
soi-même vision parce que ça valorise un
jeune qui n'a pas forcément accès le jeu
de golf
à partir du moment qu'un jeune fille
joue au golf il devient du responsable
se calme un petit peu tendu demande qui
va de plus en plus vite
il développe un certain compréhension de
l'environnement de ses responsabilités
vis-à-vis de l'employeur non ce qu'ils
ont comme qui rigole avec nous ils ont
cessé les parents qui ont venu vers moi
soyons lundi comment qu'est-ce que je
peux faire mon fils ma fille continue à
jouer parce que il s'est calmé ils sont
devenus plus responsable mais quel est
l'accueil qui fait dodo lé golfe rebboah
les regarde comme des comme des ovnis où
il est bête assez facilement si on amène
les jeunes directement dans les gares
sans avoir déjà joué
c'est sûr que ça comme il est même moins
mais moi j'ai pas envie de faire ça je
pense que c'est pas correct dans
l'hygiène pour découvrir le cas
directement sur un parcours de golf
au contraire nous on fait quatre cinq
six séances dans les écoles sous les
terrains de foot sur les terrains de
rugby
on les initie sur le geste pour qu'ils
ont une certaine compréhension des
règles et tout le reste et on emmène
quand on amène les jeunes dans une vraie
gauche par la suite noté jerry sont les
yeux grands ouverts un jardin et c'est
le paradis c'est par ces paradis
c'est fabuleux et en plus ils sont
capables de jouer donc nos réactions des
membres
c'est série perd favorable je suis
justement pour dire que comme on peut
par la suite faire venir lui dedans mais
qu'ils prennent
s'il vous plaît les visées j'ai la
chance d'en tirer certaines jeunes dans
les quartiers par exemple à montrer à
m'enfermer et d'orly qui ont aujourd'hui
devenu professionnel dégâts c'est génial
et ryder cup qui arrive
vous êtes en relation d'ailleurs inclus
de fondations qui s'appelle la ryder cup
trust et peut-être que des jeunes qui
fait qu'ils sont avec vous ils seront
avec vous dans les mois qui viennent
vont participer à cette ryder cup au
pôle l'organisation en tout cas de cette
ryder cup
le projet golf éducative a gagné le
concours européen
il y a quelques années et en conséquence
pendant le raid capture intention
d'amener plusieurs jeunes des différents
quartiers ou garde nationale donc je dis
tout de suite à polar métais directeur
d'autres que moi je veux plusieurs
tickets pour la bas et justement on va
emmener si j'aime la très bonne idée
pourquoi pas ces jeunes prennent bien
sûr avec les six seraient donc mieux
billoët si un moment pénible dans cette
émission est très amusant on va aller
vous regardez sung et et bien que vous
soyez un pro bien que vous soyez un
excellent golfeur donc on va quand même
se mettre votre swing un autre pro
peut-être qu'il aura des remarques à
faire on sait jamais il est gentil mais
fier regarde bien
wang
[Musique]
bonjour sébastien ruffier bonjour palais
ça va très bien très bientôt ça va très
bien comme chaque numéro 2 par 70 va
analyser le swing de l'autre invité je
rappelle que sébastien rouquette
nationale c'est l'entraîneur le coach de
l'équipe première
donc même si cette proue bon temps des
séries de sprints et bill owens il ya
peut-être des choses à dire on s'est
donc se laisse avec bill owens est ce
qu'on peut observer en tout cas sur la
vidéo de profil là c'est
qu'effectivement quand une conteuse
swing tu as tendance à avoir une perte
de salaire à se redresser
lors du bac swing à mon sens à ses
billets en fait bill à ta posture on le
donnait pas placer suffisamment droit
notamment au niveau du bassin c'est à
dire qu'ici on voit que la ceinture est
trop à l'horizontale ce qui fait que ton
bassin n'est pas placé tu vois la
difficulté à faire un pivot complet sans
trop de blessés donc ce que je te
préconise simplement club dans le dos
point de contact au niveau du coccyx
points de contacts au niveau des
dorsales
voilà tu gardes les enquêtes avec le bas
du corps ils sont excellents par contre
il faudra longtemps il va sortir un tout
petit peu plus les fesses en arrière de
manière à ce que cette portion du dos
soit plus à plat ça va te permettre très
simplement de pouvoir faire ton pivot
comme tu le sais aussi bien que moi sans
avoir de perdre donc ça va t'amener un
petit peu plus de régularité
voilà simplement dans la frappe
donc on va en fait les problèmes qui
sont liés à ça c'est que les anges
tourne trop le corps se redresse donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait on replace le bas
du corps manière à ce qu'ils puissent
faire uniquement de travail qu'il a à
faire et pas plus et à partir de là tu
vas pouvoir tourner dans les angles très
facilement
c'est juste qu'à faire un tout petit
truc j'ai remarqué que tu as tendance à
dégripper au sommet c'est-à-dire à
lâcher le club a fait l'exercice
classique salaire tu prends un ti ou un
petit bout de papier tue le coin si si
et si jamais il tombe quand tu es au
sommet du cqa tendance à lâcher donc il
faut augmenter un tout petit peu la
pression au travail et sur une pression
peut-être un peu plus constant dans les
mains pendant le match mais voilà
[Musique]
vous le savez l'open de france pour une
nouvelle dimension avec l'arrivée d'un
partenaire chinois à schoenau fait le
point avec michael et demi d'euros et
nicolas kirillovitch l'officialisation
était attendue depuis plusieurs semaines
elle est intervenue ce lundi 9 janvier
au ministère des affaires étrangères à
paris
l'open de france organisé tous les ans
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines va être désormais sponsorisé
pendant cinq ans par le groupe chinois à
chênée spécialisée dans le transport
aérien
la dotation de la compétition va être
triplés elle va atteindre 6,6 millions
d'euros ce qui en fera l'un des tournois
les plus prestigieux en europe au niveau
des tournois européens se met à nouveau
plutôt en phare en lumière et ça donne
du coup un éclairage nouveau club
aujourd'hui avec tout ce que nous avons
appelé ben on s'aperçoit que non
seulement nous avons un nouveau sponsor
non seulement c'est un sponsor important
mais surtout nous entrons dans une
nouvelle dimension
mais là cette fois ça nous permet de
faire partie des plus gros tournois
européens et surtout de nous de nous
positionner carrément au niveau mondial
conséquence directe ce nouveau
partenariat va attirer les journalistes
du monde entier surtout des joueurs de
renommée internationale à partir de
cette année les irlandais harrington et
laurie et le français alexander levy ont
déjà annoncé leur participation
ça arrive aussi en même temps que la
ryder cup 2018 donc on va parler de plus
en plus du golf en france et c'est sûr
que nous jeunes joueurs on essaye
d'amener notre petite touche de jeunesse
pour que les gens s'intéressent de plus
en plus et essaye de on essaye aussi de
démocratiser un peu ce sport pour voir
ces stars du golf en action il faudra
être patient la 101e édition de l'open
de france est programmée du 29 juin au 2
juillet au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
la découverte de ce numéro 2 par 78 sél
exclusif golf de bêtement aux aidants
des yvelines tout près de poissy et
c'était un golf qui a été dessiné par le
grand champion allemand bernhard
longueur romain villard bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le directeur jacques directeur
d'exclusive golf alors on est on est en
haut là on est en plein mois de janvier
il ya encore des gens qui jouent là
c'est vrai malgré -5° effectivement on a
des gens qui sont sur le parcours depuis
ce matin une trentaine de joueurs voilà
on est drôle 18h devant 18 c'est
effectivement l'arrivée du duc du
parcours on est justement au pied du bus
du club house donc l'exclusif les
domaines de béton c'est un domaine de 70
hectares un parcours 18 trous signé
bernard longueur berne un langage grand
grand champion allemand avec ce numéro
un mondial qui a gagné d'ailleurs le
masters c'est qui a signé ce parcours en
1981 en 1989 89 à une petite trentaine
de noms un peu moins on fêtera les 30
ans effectivement dans deux ans après
notre ryder cup 2018 effectivement donc
on est sur un terrain et historique ya
même une tour qui s'appelle la tour
jeanne d'arc tout à fait alors c'est une
tour qui date du 11e et qui servait de
tour de guet pour les invasions de la
ville de paris il y avait des tunnels
qu'il allait jusqu'à la collégiale de
poissy justement pour sonner les églises
à cette époque là on l'appelle la tour
jeanne d'arc parce que pour l'histoire
jeune d'à que la récupérer ou aux
anglais en 1424
à ces périodes là encore voilà d'où le
nom de la jordanne d'arc 2 le nom donc
terrain historique mais club
alors quand même vécu une trentaine
c'est quand même bien pour un point oui
c'est vrai moi c'est effectivement ça
commence à faire ses effets dans un dans
un domaine en matière de chasse à
l'époque 1 c'est à dire que c'était un
domaine boisé à domaine de chasse on est
sur une gentille au maire du 18e qui a
effectivement été totalement rénové et
et qui constituent le club axonais qui
constitue le club house sourde
d'aujourd'hui auraient misé récents
airbus avait effectivement une extension
de nombreux salons et qui nous permet
également de proposer toute activité
séminaires mariages etc
alors le golf de bâtiment fait partie du
groupe du golfe
oui beyou golf aujourd'hui c'est 50 golf
en france en vie on fait partie
également du réseau le club qui compte
134 parcours en france et presque 800
aujourd'hui avec l'étranger indice est
énorme oui tout à fait c'est à dire que
quand vous êtes membre d'un parcours du
golf
elle avait la possibilité de jouer sur
tous les autres également et vous avez
une carte qui permet d'avoir des
réductions sur le réseau de clubs donc
et on décédé là beaucoup à l'étranger ce
qui veut dire que quand vous partez au
maroc quand vous partez en espagne quand
vous partez même maintenant en chine un
chiffre aussi en chine si on a soumis un
temps plus effective mais là on est dans
la région parisienne dans le grand paris
donc on vous dit prendre un abonnement
oui sur 18 golf tout à fait on a créé
même un nouveau produit cette année sert
que auparavant vous avez le choix de
prendre est des formules proxis téoz est
membre de deux golfs à progrès limités
où vous avez la france entière et on
s'est rendu compte que beaucoup de nos
clients ne sortait pas forcément d'île
de france
donc on à 2017 créer une cotisation qui
permet aux joueurs d'être membres
surtout les golf le golf de la région
parisienne et d'avoir 50 % extérieur ce
qui nous a permis de diminuer un petit
peu nos tarifs de cotisation oui alors
avec ses 18 clubs de la région
parisienne quelqu'un on est assuré de
jouer de coeur jouer tout le temps quoi
c'est ça l'avantagé
bah rien que sur paris ça fait 18 21
parcours donc il ya deux il ya de quoi
faire c'est c'est aussi très agréable
parce que vous pouvez jouer tous les
week-ends on va dire sur l'un des gaules
ferait même si des golfs ont des
compétitions et que le parcours et
charles etc
vous pouvez jouer de toute façon vous
pouvez toujours trouver votre bonheur
on peut venir
peyo jeune fille mais bien entendu on
est ouverts 363 jours par an mais voilà
même envoyé aujourd'hui on n'est pas
fermés au green fillon peut prendre la d
acheter d grigny sur internet on peut
très bien effectivement réservé et venir
pour jouer un bon quand même sur le
parcours pour everything will ben ali de
bernard lambert vers la longueur c'était
un grand joueur de faire notamment
ferrée près l'on va être très très droit
avec ses chais quand même parce qu'il
faut être adroit rien alors il a fait un
parcours vraiment à son image de jeu
c'est à dire que c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille énormément ses trajectoires de
ben ali
c'est à dire que beaucoup de draw
beaucoup de fed et le parcours il
ressemble totalement c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui le parcours de bêtement
la distance du drive ne sert à rien ce
qu'il faut absolument celle après six
mois si j'en rêve vous avez déjà c'est
assez rare vous avez 5 par 3 et 5 par 5
et donc forcément 8 par quatre alors
qu'en général on génère n'est sur 4 4 4
par 4 par cinq et chaque parent 5
il faut à chaque fois faire deux très
bons coups pour obtenir le green en deux
coups et du frp même parfois des coups
forcément obligatoirement en effet c'est
à dire effet à droite et sa gauche le
droit ou fed pour pouvoir avoir le style
le green en ciblant deuxième coup on dit
que c'est un parcours qu'on peut jouer
avec deux stratégies soient offensifs
soit de manière plus prudente offensives
et défensives sens et c'est souvent ce
que je dis et c'est vrai qu'à l'heure
après on fait aussi beaucoup de
compétitions en scramble qui permet
justement d'avoir ces deux philosophies
de jeu dans la même équipe puisque quand
on voit dans les grandes compétitions au
type le grand prix on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement c'est difficile pour
les joueurs d'arriver à obtenir des
scores le record du parcours aujourd'hui
et 69 chez les jeunes puisque est pas
vraiment énorme et je crois que c'est
quand même extrêmement difficile c'est à
dire que plus vous commencez à avoir
confiance au parcours puis on me donnait
faut faire attention attention parce
qu'il est capable de faire un triple
bogey assez rapidement il ya un site via
le site du golf où elle pouvait aller
sur le site golf de bêtement vous pouvez
suivre ce petit tube golf où justement
il ya absolument tout le golfe qui sont
répertoriés donc n'hésitez pas à nous
rendre visite que ce soit pour des
jeunes et profiter de notre grande
terrasse venir essayer le golfe on est
vraiment à 15 minutes de paris une
saveur grand plaisir qu'on retrouve
absolument tout le monde
vous êtes un directeur heureux tout à
fait et passionné merci beaucoup je vous
en prie notre séquence matériel alors
les clubs on peut les acheter neuf
naturellement eu rope eux aussi d
acheter d'occasion au déstockage on va
voir comment
j'évoque vidéo bonjour vous êtes le
responsable de golf en stock et golf en
stock c'est à la fois des clubs
d'occasion et puis du déstockage on va
parler des deux on va commencer par
l'occasion parce que ya de plus en plus
de joueurs qui vous laissent des clubs
en dépôt pour que vous défendiez tout à
fait tout à fait ils ont pas forcément
le temps de s'occuper de la revente de
leur matériel et donc ils viennent nous
voir
ça fait des années qu'on est sûr qu'on
est numéro un sur le déstockage et
l'occasion est donc ça nous permet de
revendre les produits rapidement on a
une cote argus qui nous permet de
valoriser par rapport selon le vrai prix
voilà le bon prix le bon prix de vente
tout à fait par rapport à un état
également on ne prend pas n'importe quoi
on cherche à prendre des clubs dans un
état correct est ce qu'il est beau dit
oui tout à fait vous avez par exemple
un tel remède teller medem 2 tout à fait
qui date de 20 kg est très récent avoir
là qui a fait toute l'année 2016
maintenant les niveaux il valait combien
9 alors fait ça c'est un produit qui
valait 449 euros et comprend la
d'occasion à 199 euros
doc et voilà pratiquement mot no non à
oui tout à fait et puis dès que le plus
ancien voilà là on a un k-way byberg
diallo qui ne vaut plus que 39 euros par
son ancienneté et son état voilà le club
a joué aussi également il reste en bon
état mais bon le tour d'attentes pour
quelqu'un qui voulait simplement des
poussées c'est long on assez rapide on a
peu de 80% de nos clubs déposée qui sont
vendus dans un sur une période d'un mois
un mois et demi ah c'est bien c'est très
rapide
oui c'est très fier mais vraiment lu aux
revendeurs et de récupérer des fonds
rapidement et de pouvoir pour pouvoir se
racheter de nouveaux matériels et puis
il ya le déstockage alors comment vous
avez tous ces clubs on va en parler qui
vous arrive comment sais tu comment ça
se passe
la durée de vie d'un club pour quelle
que soit la marque est dur puis d'un an
il sur le marché au bout d'un an feed ah
oui c'est très très rapide c'est de plus
en plus rapide ce qui fait que les
produits arrivent chez nous à des prix
relativement attractif
les marques veulent revendre les
nouveautés et donc se débarrasser de
barras dans ce produit mais entre nous
il ya autant de progrès technique et
technologique qui fait qu' il faut y
croire il faut il croire à tout à faire
mais oui vous avez quand même google
ingénieurs dans toutes ses marques et
travaille énormément au niveau des
matériaux composites pour faire évoluer
les manches en graphite et également la
tolérance des têtes de clubs là on était
sûr et même de tout à l'heure occasion
il avait lui même demandé stockage léger
le même en déstockage à un prix
attractif on est à 40 % de la valeur 269
euros mais pour un produit neuf garantie
1 an bien évidemment voilà une petite
différence quand même l'occasion quand
même moins cher oui tout à fait mais
celui-là même personne ne saurait jamais
servi alors ya des clubs pour facile
allez on a également des clubs un peu
plus flashy mais également à ces femmes
pour femmes
on a également du déstockage pour femmes
femmes femmes seniors
il faut dire qu'autant les mecs y
revendre vite leurs clubs et des femmes
sont plus conservatrices beaucoup plus
fidèle que nous et conservent leur
matériel plus longtemps voilà il
faudrait alors de chez vous on trouve
des clubs allemands mais on trouve aussi
des sacs on voit aussi des chaussures
chaussures les vêtements géval des
balles des gangs et vannes oc chariot à
oui tout à fait on a vraiment de tout il
éprouvait les balles se courait aussi il
ya une rotation également d'une inde une
année à peu près pour les balais calme
donc c'est une sorte de caverne d'ali
baba
tout à fait et on peut donc s'équiper à
moindre coût quel que soit son niveau 1
on a des clubs pour les bons joueurs
mais également pour des joueurs
lascombes hewitt n qui veulent s'amuser
avec un produit de fax et ajoutant
notamment tout à fait ça fait combien de
temps qu'il existe d'autres stocks golf
en stocks existent depuis
je crois ventes en fin d'année c'est
vrai qu'on peut aussi trouver des clubs
d'occasion ou des clubs de déstockage
sur des sites internet y est le vôtre
il ya du rhône mais il ya également des
sites où il faut se méfier quand même
une fois jetés en connaissance de cause
car il ya quand même beaucoup
il ya un marché de contrefaçons ah oui
ah oui il ya beaucoup de faux il faut se
méfier
il ya des photos sur la wii sur internet
où il faut se méfier a donc fait
attention
bof des plus tôt vont c'est ici alors
c'est plus sûr de s'adresser à des
professionnels directement tout à fait
merci beaucoup et l'on devine aussi
patrice on se retrouve ici à orange free
avec patricia moone à lubuk dans la
rubrique astuces de champion mon
patricia je compte sur toi parce que je
crois que ma balle aidant très mauvaise
position
je m'étais dit que je te promets ah oui
effectivement tabac les juste un tout
petit peu plus gai là aide moi pas tu
alors patrice en effet la balle allait
bien enfoncer ce qui est le plus
important c'est la façon tu vas créer de
l'énergie pour que la balle sorte la
plupart des gens essayent de vraiment
forcer pour qu'elle sorte
moi je te conseille d'utiliser l'inertie
le poids de la tête de clubs et de
garder du rythme quand tu sais ton swing
alors là tu vois en fait ce qui est
important pour moi c'est vraiment de
sentir comme si la tête de clubs elle
faisait elle était très très lourde et
que je ne peux pas la tirer trop fort il
faut vraiment j'ai dû rythme pour la
laisser exploser le sable
ou fantastiques avons alors siphat
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]